This video is sponsored by amazon prime video
once upon a time there was a
little girl named jessica hyde
jessica hyde had a daddy who was a genius
scientist now jessica and her daddy were
held by an evil villain named mr rabbit
he made daddy hyde create horrible viruses
until one day a hero named artemis broke out
jessica and her daddy mr rabbit sends his henchmen
the harvest after them the harvest kidnapped
daddy so now jessica hyde has to save him
but that's just the mythology if you're smart
if you're really really smart you can study it
and decipher all the real life epidemics it
predicted
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going to be my utopia episode 1 video
i'vebeen doing videos for amazon's the boys season 2 episodes recently and they just released anothervery twisted comic book series based on utopia
there's a bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'll be hosting
a giveaway for amazon prime memberships so you
can watch all these shows for free all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and post your
favorite moment from the show on the video in the
comments below big warning though this video does
contain spoilers from utopia episode 1 i'll do
top 10 moments and easter eggs from the show
as we go along just like in my videos from the
boys starting with number 10 the origin of the
show if you have no idea where this came from
utopia actually started out as a british show
this new one is totally different and doesn't
have anything to do with that older show it adds
this dimension of the metaphorical and literal
comic book easter eggs in a big part of the first
episode are conspiracy theorists fans decoding
easter eggs in a comic book that's created within
the world of the show that seemingly helps them
predict the future it's an ensemble cast with a
couple big names like john cusack and rayne wilson
from the office you'll probably recognize at least
some of the other main cast members from some
other recent shows and movies the story picks
up when two newlyweds inherit a house from the
wife's grandfather after he's believed to have
died and when they go to move in they find out
that he was a bit of a hoarder and seemingly a
conspiracy theorist so they spend a huge montage
cleaning the house and during that find a bunch
of pages of artwork from a mysterious comic book
project the comic book is called utopia and even
though they have no idea what it is at first they
figure they can sell it make a little money from
the collector's market so they create an auction
to take place at their in-universe version of a
comic-con and news about the unpublished comic
book spreads like wildfire through their fandom
then they go through the big montage to introduce
you to most of the main cast members who are all
part of this tighter knit group of ultra hardcore
fans of that comic book series all trying to
find a way to get it in their hands number
eight there's this ongoing mystery about the
creation of the comic book and the quote-unquote
unknown artist behind the pages that all the main
characters are after the unpublished work that
they found in the remains of their new house is
actually the sequel series to a long-running title
called dystopia the sequel series is titled utopia
which the show takes its name from when the series
picks up it's been a long time since they've heard
any news about what's going to happen to the comic
book series that they all love so much they have
all these conspiracy theories about what happens
to the characters within the universe of the comic
book like your favorite manga ends and the creator
never tells you what happens to the characters
nicks so when it's revealed that there is a
sequel to the story everyone goes crazy the actual
dystopia and utopia comic books in the world of
the show follow the adventures of a girl named
jessica hyde who's the daughter of a scientist who
are both held captive by the villain of the series
called mr rabbit who makes her father create all
these different viruses and biological weapons
until one day they're rescued by another hero
within the series called artemis then within the
comic series mr rabbit's henchmen chased them down
capture her father and then jessica hyde's mission
becomes saving him again from mr rabbit but
because the sequel hadn't appeared yet before they
all wonder what ends up happening to her and her
father within the world of the tv show the comic
book series that everyone's this huge fan of is
relatively new it debuted in 2014 so it's not like
the title had been running for a long time when
the show picks up in present day it's supposed to
be 2020 when they find that utopia sequel comic
book number seven the x-files level conspiracy
twist to the show though is that the main group
of protagonists believe that the comic book itself
predicted all of the major epidemics that
happened in the real world of the show that is
long before they happened like the
heartland those are all very real very
terrible things but within the world of the show
the characters believed that there were clues in
the comic books before those actually happened
in the real world so they think that the comic
book is predicting the future but within the final
issue of the dystopia comic book before the sequel
the creator teased that he would be doing the
utopia sequel but suddenly all news about it went
silent until it was found by the granddaughter
and her husband so they have no idea what's
going on they never read the comic book they're
not part of the fandom so they just found some
pages that they think are worth some money to
some fans so number six while they're all getting
hyped up for the utopia auction at this comic con
event the show goes into another montage revealing
more of the main cast and the villains of the
episode like these two weirdos who are seemingly
coming to the comic con to bid on the book along
with the other group of maines and a ton of other
hardcore fans of the series 2020 in real life has
been a pretty interesting year to say the least so
the series itself is a little prescient the mains
talk about feeling like it's the end of the world
and the reason they desperately need to win
the auction on this utopia comic book is so
that they can decode the hidden easter eggs that
will tell them the future in all the bad things
that are going to happen because even though
the comic book supposedly predicts the future
as i said everything that it foretells are
global pandemics like biblical level plagues
number five the mains themselves all have
varying degrees of messed up backstories
they don't completely reveal everyone's secrets
in the first episode but they're meant to come off
varying levels of closeted and not so closeted
conspiracy theorists who just happen to be fans
of the comic book series as well so they spend
a lot of time at the actual comic con event
distinguishing their hardcore level of fandom
from the more traditional casual comic book fans
of the series who don't know anything about the
truth behind the utopia comic series or that it
might have some connection to real world events
the big twist of the comic book is that they're
actually kind of right about the book predicting
the future it's just not quite what they think
it is though number four the introduction of the
two hit men the show isn't subtle at all about the
two creepiest mains who wind up being full-blown
serial killers they do get a bit of a funny intro
during the episode but it turns into creepy town
on a dime so it's not a huge surprise that they
wind up being the main antagonist of the episode
not necessarily the main villains as they would
have to have been hired by someone if they are
hitmen they do have something of a funny montage
of different comic book fans trying to snag the
book during the auction but it's pretty clear
the husband and wife have no idea what they found
or how her grandfather was connected to the real
world conspiracies that are seemingly revealed
through the easter eggs in the book so the number
three the hitmen take the list from the auction
and go around killing all the participants who
saw the different pages they never fully answer
all the questions about who they're working for
or why it's so important or necessary for them to
kill everyone who saw the new utopia comic book
but it's implied that they're also responsible
for the disappearance of the grandfather who's
the supposed artist of the comic series and one
of the creators they try to get a little comedic
with some of their kills but once they do track
down the buyer of the actual utopia book they
barely miss the little kid who's already snatched
it and he escapes having witnessed the whole thing
other than the reveal that he's not the porsche
owning ladies man that he's been pretending to be
to the group in the episode we don't know a lot
about his backstory preceding the episode only
that he's just another one of the active members
of this group decoding easter eggs in the stories
but number two the young kid grant steals
the utopia comic book they reveal the truth
about his mysterious character that they've been
texting through their group the whole time they'd
never really seen him or heard his voice before
so they just assumed that he was the wealthy
middle-aged ladies man james bond type that
he'd been portraying himself as this whole time
to his credit he does go full james bond during
the episode in order to steal the comic book from
the buyer but it completely goes off the rails
spectacularly when he comes back to his hotel
room with the booth babe at the comic-con and then
things go completely out of the frying pan into
the fire when the two hitmen show up and gunned
down both the buyer and the girl he's barely able
to escape but they do see him so they know that he
has the book and they know that he's a little kid
his name isn't on their hit list but the other
main character's names are those members of the
utopia fan group also don't know who he really
is or that he actually got the comic book that
they all think is gone to them forever but then
number one jessica hyde actually shows up
in the final scene of the episode so this raises a
whole bunch of questions about how she's connected
to the dystopia and utopia comic books that
everyone has been after for the episode she's
super hardcore too she doesn't look like she's
had a shower a change of clothes in a hot minute
doesn't bother to help any of the victims but
the hitmen did say that that paralytic would
wear off eventually so at least a few of them
might be able to walk out of that hotel room
once you've had a chance to check out the series
let me know in the comments what you think of it
is just another twist on the comic book genre
now we have things like the boys in this series
utopia which are direct parodies of that stuff
so it's cool to see how this type of culture
will evolve in the next several years as comic
book movies and tv shows just continue to mature
the utopia show is out on amazon prime video right
now check it out and let me know what you think of
it in the comments below and thanks to them amazon
prime video for sponsoring this everyone click
here for the boys season 2 episode 6 video and
click here for that brand new marvel avengers wandavision
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!